Jimmy Hendrix once famously said on a
talk show in 1969 link below and I'm
paraphrasing here that compliments make
him feel awkward and he doesn't like
them I agree
compliments make me feel weird too but
only when they're done a certain way
sometimes they feel good and what I'm
going to explain to you is how the right
way to do it and the wrong way to do it
and also this is going to lead into
expectations and and whether you should
have expectations of people or not how
to do that properly so stick around and
keep watching and maybe you'll learn a
little something
so first the compliment thing yeah
compliments almost always make me feel
awkward but not if they're done a
certain way I've seen people have done
it to me in the awkward way and I've
known a couple people that do it in a
really good way so usually it's people
that are less experienced with being
social and developing equal
relationships that do it the wrong way
it's usually people that are I'm trying
to think another way to say this without
sounding condescending but people that
are not at my level and whatever I'm
doing or don't have the potential to
easily be at my level at what I'm doing
those are the people who give a high
compliment let me give you an example I
play guitar like the old Hendricks and I
don't consider myself a very good
guitarist but I love it and I will play
all day if given the opportunity and
don't have much else to do and yeah sure
I'll come up with some cool stuff but in
also in there I'm gonna riff around and
come up with some terrible stuff I know
if I don't find myself to be
particularly good but you know given
enough time and enough chances of
interests I'll come up with something
good and it's it's like that burp out
anything in any any hobby you know I
think Hendrix would agree
he was a jammer he didn't study he
didn't know theory it was just jam and
eventually come up with something good
and people were like oh he's the best no
he didn't think it was the best he's
just got good so when people suddenly
come out you're like oh my goodness you
are like so good at that you're the best
I can't oh my they're just like you know
in all its like don't be at all man all
I did was sit here and strum and mess
around how I came up with it anybody
could do that it's not really that
special it's just like are you willing
to spend time on it then it can happen
and you know he felt the same and I
think that's why he felt awkward about
all the compliments he got and that's
often why I feel awkward about
compliments cuz I feel like the things
I'm doing anybody could do don't
compliment before if you want to do it
don't go do it you don't have to be
impressed by me I mean you to be
inspired by me and you know that's
that's something I've learned to take in
stride over time like I used to get
awkward and try to compliment the person
back and then the whole conversation
would start feeling weird now I've
learned to just say things kind of move
on and you know it's good to have your
work appreciated so that's that's
something I think if vo Hendrix was able
to keep on going with this thing would
have eventually realized and probably
took him stride better because it did
take me a while I don't think I don't
think in my 20s I was good at taking
compliments but once I got to my
thirties I think I started to figure it
out a little better so I started taking
it better and even if I noticed it was
an awkward compliment I was still just
saying thanks and a lot of that came
from performing and stuff as when I was
in a band I didn't I did perform I would
get compliments when I feel like I
didn't deserve them and I couldn't
really you know and they were often fans
so I couldn't really you know discredit
their compliments but also when that
happens it's really hard to tell if the
person is being sarcastic or not because
to you it feels like okay I'm not really
doing anything that special you know I'm
strumming power chords for God's sakes
anybody gets strum power chords you
don't need to thank me but okay okay so
based on that it feels like to you when
you you're just like you know doing some
pretty basic and someone really loves it
it's hard to tell if they see how basic
it is in our making fun of you or if
they genuinely don't know and it just
sounds good to them and they do
appreciate it so it's really hard to
detect what their being sarcastic or not
chances are they're not the majority of
the time they're not because if they are
they should be he's giving you some kind
of signal like that it's sarcastic
otherwise there
badda communicating so most likely they
are actually impressed and just you know
don't know that it's a sin not that part
of a thing so that whole thing makes it
a bit awkward but just roll with it just
say thanks so you might be asking at
this point so how do I properly give a
compliment with without it sounding
awkward - making everything
awkward I think the best way is just a
simple I like it not that's it
does something it says something you
know you just you just kind of give them
you know the thumbs up just like I like
it nice you know I like it sound cool
anything like that is excellent and that
can that can lead in to your questions
about the thing it was like I like what
you did there can you walk with your
thought process I want to understand or
something like that you know perfect way
to compliment someone without a me
making it feel awkward because you're
giving them something to go off of
rather than just like if you just say oh
that was amazing knowing the only reply
that the person can have is thanks you
know that's it but if you say
thank you like it
and to ask my follow-up question they
can start talking about it and they know
that you're interested could you like it
and it's you know it's very conversation
starter and that's way better way better
way to do now the reason I am no longer
impressed by people in no longer place
what I want to say duties on people that
i 100% expect them to do because the
expectation leads to disappointment I'm
sure you guys have all heard that it's a
pretty common mantra or whatever wisdom
pretty ancient wisdom that you have
expectations of somebody you're gonna be
disappointed
it's guaranteed I think it's often why
employees get in trouble from their
bosses the bosses place expectations on
them employee doesn't make meet the
expectations and boss gets a little
upset
etc etc a pretty understandable thing
but even as a boss you shouldn't place
that kind of expectation on someone
especially above their means I think
it's better to place an incentive on
somebody to let them know that how much
they would be appreciated if they do it
to give them some some outs just in case
they can that are acceptable like look
really neat that's done by the end of
the day if you could do it that would be
so much appreciated and look if it gets
to whatever time and it doesn't look
like it's going to be done just let me
know as soon as possible it's not a big
deal I just need to know that way I can
make accommodations and that way there's
no disappointment like they'll try to
get it done because they want to be
appreciated and maybe there can be other
incentives it doesn't have to always be
appreciation but you can't go wrong with
appreciation because hey it's free to
give and people love it so you can't go
wrong with that so if they're not
getting it done
they have an out there saying look I
can't I can't quite get it done and they
know that's gonna be acceptable because
you already explained that and then that
makes you feel okay to so the the area
where this becomes not okay and it's
more of a gray area how what do you see
if it's gray it's actually a black area
or white I guess it depends how you look
at it black meaning bad white means good
no racial implications intended
just okay just trying to make the
variation with the gravy in the middle
the lack of communication is the only
thing it could be a problem here and
that's
and that's all that so for example
comes to the end of the day they didn't
send you a communication saying they
could get it done so you expect that
it's probably done and you know I got
days over didn't send me a communication
say and they couldn't quite get it
finished so it's we're good to go
then you find out later that didn't get
done and they just didn't say anything
and you were pretty sure you're a pretty
darn clear about it then what where do
you go from there
cuz now you're disappointed and in this
situation I think you have every reason
to be because they failed at the social
contract of communicating to you and
that's that's actually really bad on
every everything every level you can
imagine every fundamental level of human
relationships so when that happens
well I think it's I think it's fair to
do what you deem necessary express your
disappointment okay
hey side rant driving sucks it's nice
being on a 70 mile-per-hour highway
going 20 miles per hour probably soon to
be a dead stop
but whatever we'll roll with it
literally so if someone breaks that
social contract of not keeping you
updated and I've been on the I've been
on the receiving end of this too I've
broken that contract and learned the
hard way
so don't don't feel too bad about
yourself you know I also learned
recently the number one predictor of
success is empathy for yourself not
being hard on yourself
actually predicts success if you're hard
on yourself and mean to yourself you're
less likely to be successful keep that
in mind so be kind of yourself you will
make mistakes so if you break that
social contract of not updating whoever
you need to update it when you weren't
gonna get the thing done you you've done
messed up done screwed up and you need
to recognize that don't be too mean to
yourself but you should you got to
recognize it and you've got to have
something if you have nothing you're
done like it's perfectly reasonable for
that person to cut you off it's
perfectly reasonable for that person to
fire you you should honestly expect to
be fired and maybe you want to
in fact I would honestly think that if
someone did that that they don't they
don't know they're not interested they
don't want to do this they want to be
fired in a way they want to do something
else and you know that's perfectly fine
but it'd be even more fine if you were
just open about it to begin with and we
didn't have to go through this whole
awkward thing of you purposely
disappointing you know that that kind of
thing so I've been there too I'm not
trying to say that I'm better than
anyone that I'd never do it or whatever
I've done it but I try my hardest not to
do it anymore because I realized how bad
it is and that only that just came with
experience the only thing the only way I
learned that was by messing up myself
and time even though it's that obvious
of a thing
it still happens so now you know maybe
you can learn for me do it
it's really beneficial to build up your
reputation in in your profession
whatever you want to do in life I do
believe that you should remain
consistent and attempt to build up that
reputation by completing your duties not
break any social contacts contracts if
you can you can get something good done
great if not it's your duty to update
update whoever you're working so we
don't do that it truly looks bad on you
and you're you're losing credit and the
thing you want to do presumably and
presumably the thing you want to do
isn't actually what you want to do if
it's okay it's a weird thing but you
know that's the way he goes
and that's that's what I think so hope
this helps somebody don't place
expectations place incentives and don't
be disappointed if you are disappointed
make sure those darn good reason so I'm
just recap OKC for whatever I repeat
if you are disappointed
it needs to be for a social contract
reason not for the actual work
ultimately it's your duty to get the
work done if you want it done not the
other person's all right
yeah and it's their duty to uphold the
social contract not necessarily get the
work done that's the point they're
tricky would I know gotta merge gotta
merge gotta merge all right I'm out
keep it real folks I'll see you in the
next video don't forget to leave a
comment down below whatever you think
about this whole thing that'll leave
anything important out maybe I did I
probably did and don't forget to smash
the like button come on I need your help
I'm only at 95 subs and you know I'd
love to keep this channel going but I
got I gotta see some I gotta see
something I gotta see some some thumbs
some kind of moving forward
all right I'm out see it